[Applause]
wow i'm here i've made it i still took a
big deal i'm looking forward to doing
this with you
now before i tell you why i want to ask
about your family and what an amazing
influence that they have been in
bringing the time movement west big time
big time yeah so you know people
watching my food network but they didn't
know you know my 50 years ago my family
moved to the states and we started the
first thai restaurants markets grocery
store in the whole history of this
country so we started thai
yeah it's wild but it's awesome to be
your cooking pad thai with you drew i
can't believe it well i'm so excited
because you're ready not only is this
one of my favorite foods but i've
attempted this on my own okay and so i'm
so excited to learn from a master well
um and you're in good hands so just
enough oil to coat the bottom how's that
sound just enough to coat the bottom you
don't need any more than that so uh
right after the oil we always want to do
aromatics and things that won't burn but
bring a lot of aroma this is a radish a
sweetened ridish you know like the
daikon radish really yeah it's pickled
uh sweet it adds a nice aroma you're
gonna throw in some dried you smell that
i do
garlic yolo let's do some garlic and
then these are dried shrimp big dried
shrimp i thought you didn't cook a lot i
think i think i'm being totally hustled
here by the way i think i think i think
you're you're a ringer i'm i'm getting
that feeling yeah i've been a studier
it's like you know i don't i'm not ready
to be a teacher i'm still a student but
i really apply myself to learn yeah but
you know what your passion for cooking
comes through though i know how much you
love the cooking uh i'm gonna go
proteins now are you cool with
that do it together come on throw it in
excellent so we're gonna go shrimp and
then uh again if you're not doing shrimp
you can do just do the tofu you can do
any protein you want to yeah and then
we're gonna watch your we actually you
do this we're gonna do something called
hot side cold side watch this we're
gonna push everything against one side
okay i'm just going to shake the pan
center up uh the heat just like you got
there beautiful we'll take an egg and
you can either crack it or lay it right
into the hot side so most people are
like oh i got to take the food out and
then i got to cook the egg and then i
can put the food back in it's such a
waste of time just do it like this is
how grandma did it yeah so you see how
you we're cooking up everything i don't
want this egg to fully set okay i want
it nice and still kind of moist and now
we'll bring it all together boom that's
it look at that oh yeah i see that
super simple
you're killing it
you're totally killing me so i was in
sun valley idaho and my whole family was
skiing right and i don't like to ski
because i've seen people in full body
casts at the airport and i know i'm
going to end up being one of them
so i am like a lodge bunny
so when i have time off i'm really
passionate about cooking when i'm like
working it's take out city totally
totally
um but when i have some time cooking is
my passion so i decided i was gonna
challenge myself to learn pad thai so
you so you set up the whole kitchen over
there i'll tell you what uh you send
bring me over we'll do a full pad thai
class while all the families are skiing
how's that sound well it's truly one of
my favorite foods on planet earth so i
was like i want to learn how it works
for sure so another big tip here right
these are called rice stick noodles yup
most people get the wrong noodles and
then they apply it incorrectly you take
the dry rice noodles you soak them in
warm water until they get nice and
pliable and now they hit the pan they
sauteing they start steaming so what
we're going to find is as we kind of
keep the noodles at the bottom they're
gonna start getting nice and soft
go drew go you got this you got this
come on
yes
yeah
yeah
yeah
all right next tip for pat perfect pad
thai um thai food is five flavors
hot sour salty sweet savory is that
umami also in the savory girl yeah
yeah
yeah
oh that bound down yo
bow down
i decided to get that right
i was like then that's umami right yeah
no you nailed it so the umami is in fish
sauce anything that's fermented gives
you umami so the the the radish gave it
gives you umami the fish sauce gives you
mommy so add to that fish sauce a lime
juice a little bit of vinegar and we're
gonna stir look at you i didn't even
tell you to stir because we're using a
little sugar in there and then we're
gonna get the sauce right in and then uh
so pad thai um who likes spicy anyone
are we spicy i do okay i do so in
thailand we would add sriracha or chili
sauce but when my family started thai
food here 50 years ago people were like
ooh a little too spicy so we wanted to
bring the color of heat without the
spice so we're doing paprika so just a
little paprika but for drew and those
like drew who like heat a little bit of
chili paste chili powder sriracha that's
the way to go right there yeah because
you want that color yeah you're so ripe
[Music]
you